bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce studio de
l'heure de vérité où nous accueillons ce
soir monsieur françois mitterrand
monsieur le président ce qui nous
regarde ce soir savent que cette 16e
édition de l'heure de vérité ne sera pas
comme les autres c'est en effet la
première fois qu'un président de la
république accepte de venir ainsi dans
l'exercice de la fonction suprême
répondre aux questions que se posent les
français alors philippe harrouard et
comme d'habitude asvp philippe harrouard
est ce qu on a déjà une première
tendance sur les questions monsieur le
président la république bonsoir depuis
19h nous avons un nombre record d'appels
et toutes les questions qui vous font
pour ce qui vous sont posées font le
tour des grands problèmes de politique
étrangère du moment mais il y a un thème
qui domine incontestablement c'est celui
de la défense est un mot qui revient
constamment c'est le mot de guerre les
français se demandent s'il y aura une
troisième guerre mondiale et certains se
demandent également si votre
intervention de ce soir monsieur le
président ne vise pas à les préparer à
l'éventualité d'une guerre en europe
la question est très clairement posée
constamment par ailleurs les thèmes qui
dominent dans les questions qui vous
sont posées sont ceux du pacifisme et du
proche orient en particulier le liban
bon la guerre monsieur le président la
guerre qui s'est rallumée hier vous le
savez à beyrouth les premiers missiles
de croisière américains qui commencent à
arriver en grande bretagne ces missiles
seront ils lançaient un jour une guerre
nucléaire est elle envisageable une
guerre qui ne toucheraient chez-nous
l'homme vivant en europe
si je vous ai demandé de venir vous même
ce soir monsieur le président ce parce
que vous êtes le mieux placé pour parler
de la guerre
vous seul disposer des informations qui
permettent de connaître les enjeux et
les risques des choix militaires parce
que vous êtes un rapport permanent que
les grands de ce monde parce que vous
êtes le chef des armées et parce que
vous avez accès par qu'on fonctionne aux
dossiers les plus secrets alors alain
duhamel qui est déjà à mes côtés marc
ulmann de rtl et paris match
ainsi qu'albert du roi d'antenne 2 vont
vous interroger pendant un quart d'heure
chacun en ayant constamment présent à
l'esprit ce chiffre 77% des français qui
ont été consultés l'été dernier par son
ge ont déclaré être mal ou très mal à
former sur cette question des fusées
américaines en europe alors alain
duhamel c'est à vous pour un quart
d'heure ont reçu le président justement
et essayant de clarifier si vous louez
bien pour commencer cette question des
euromissiles et des rapports est ouest
alors la première question naturellement
qui se pose c'est celle que pose et
téléspectateurs c'est il ya le blocage
des négociations actuelles entre les
américains et les soviétiques à genève
il y a les missiles soviétiques qui sont
déjà implantés il ya les missiles
américains qui commencent à l'être
quels sont les risques de cette crise
jusqu où est ce que ça peut aller est ce
qu'il ya des risques de dérapage je
voudrais répondre aussi à la
présentation de monsieur de virieu mais
juste un mot pour dire que j'ai
parfaitement conscience de la fonctions
que j'exerce en particulier ce soir qui
est celle d'expliquer aux français des
choses sérieuses je suis par la
constitution et par le vote des français
le garant de l'indépendance nationale et
de l'intégrité du territoire et je
rempli la fonction de chef des armées
j'ajoute que puisque notre stratégie
repose sur la dissuasion sur la
détention d'une force atomique capable
d'interdire à quiconque de songer à nous
attaquer toute une série de questions se
posent pour nous de la faire sur ce que
c'est que cette force et on risque de se
perdre dans des explications techniques
ou mécanique
je vais vous dire tout de suite quelque
chose de très clair la pièce maîtresse
de la stratégie de dissuasion en france
c'est le chef de l'état c'est moi car
tout dépend de sa détermination nord-est
ce sont des matériaux inertes enfin
jusqu'à la décision jusqu'à la décision
qui doit consister précisément à faire
que l'on ne s'en sert et veut pas alors
jean-pierre maintenant votre question
les missiles de voir qu'est ce que c'est
du missile est une notion assez obscures
je pense que beaucoup de français ont vu
le départ des satellites plus départ des
astronautes et ils ont vu une formidable
poussée à la base le visa feu et puis
une fusée partir dans l'espace
mieux c'est un peu cela missiles c'est
un instrument de guerre qui fait
lui-même sa mise à feu une fusée par
cette fusée elle a une tête ou plusieurs
têtes c'est à dire qu'elle dispose de
plusieurs moyens de réaliser plusieurs
explosions c'est ce qu'on appelle des
charges nucléaires et cela va là où ce
qu'ils ont voulu
ont choisi leur but il existe diverses
sortes de missiles ou d'armement
nucléaire
il ya ce qu'on appelle les armements
tactique nous attardons pas ça ne va pas
très loin bien que ce soit un meurtrier
et c'est un peu dépassé
bien qu'on s'en serve as encore je veux
dire dans les plans d'état major il y a
les missiles c'est là que va se situer
notre conversation que l'on dit
intermédiaire de portée intermédiaire
c'est tout simple par rapport au débat
qui nous occupe actuellement ce tout
simplement des missiles des fusées qui
ne traverse pas l'atlantique
c'est pourquoi les troisièmes ce missile
le troisième catégorie ce sont les
missiles intercontinentaux dit au fonds
stratégique
bon je résume un peu peut-être pour des
spécialistes mais c'est plus facile à
comprendre pour nous allons d'abord
parler des missiles intermédiaire oui
c'est le cas des ss 20 ce sera le cas où
ce serait le cas des piercings de farine
2 et des missiles de croisière
un américain qui serait implantée en
europe alors la première question il ya
une situation de tension
en ce moment il y a le blocage des
négociations qui existe est justement
sur ces missiles intermédiaires ce qu'on
appelle les euromissiles il ya le début
ces jours-ci d'implantation des missiles
de croisière et bientôt des piercings 2
et puis il ya les missiles soviétiques
les 16-20 qui eux sont déjà implantés
alors la première question que je crois
les gens se posent aujourd'hui au moment
où on parle c est ce que cette tension
risque de déboucher dans les semaines
qui viennent sur une crise
internationale majeure ou pas et puis
ensuite si vous le voulez bien quand
vous m'aurez répondu on en viendra aux
questions qu'ils se posent sur la
négociation de 0 missiles qui sont très
importantes
et puis ensuite à la force de frappe
française donc on en viendra car j'ai
besoin de le savoir à une explication
des forces qui se trouve face à face
absolument également je pense de la
question essentielle pour la france
est-ce que l'armement français va entrer
en compte toute la négociation tout à
fait tout à fait je pense alors sur la
question principale que vous plaît ne me
posais qui est exprimé par monsieur
harrouard à l'instant oui lequel ou fond
nous transmettez l'opinion générale les
risques de guerre je pense que l'opinion
française a des raisons tout à fait
fondé de s'inquiéter tout à fait fonte
et parce qu'après tout la crise des
euromissiles c'est la crise la plus
sérieuse que le monde ait connue depuis
les crises de cuba et de berlin qui
comme vous savez on représentait des
moments forts et souvent dramatique de
l'après guerre dans lequel nous sommes
mais il ne faut pas perdre pourtant son
sang-froid et l'opinion française doit
garder le sien nous n'en sommes pas là
les crises précédentes ont été maîtrisés
celles ci doivent l'être à leur tour
il faut pour cela répondre à un certain
nombre de conditions vous vous savez
monsieur duhamel
personne ne veut la guerre ni à l'est ni
à l'ouest mais la question qui est posée
c'est de savoir si la situation qui
s'aggrave de jour en jour n'échappera
pas à la décision des vrais responsables
alors ces conditions je ne les énumérait
pas je dirai seulement que pour moi elle
commence par une condition fondamentale
qui est l'équilibré des forces en
présence pour que la guerre n'éclate pas
bhl alors justement ça ça m'amène
exactement à la seconde question à
laquelle j'avais pensé votre position de
fond sur cette question c'est celle
d'une réduction équilibrée des armements
et est le premier à la première question
que les spécialistes ont à l'esprit
c'est est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui ou pas
équilibre des armements et et votre
thèse c'est en ce qui concerne les
missiles intermédiaires comme vous ne
l'avez expliqué tout à l'heure ce que
vaut sa démission intermédiaire pour
l'instant il n'y a pas cet équilibre
c'est un point qui est controversé je
crois que ce serait bien que vous
expliquez votre position sans effet ce
sont ces missiles là qui sont en
question
c'est cela dont on discute
essentiellement à genève c'est autour de
ces missiles que tantôt les états unis
d'amérique
tantôt l'union soviétique fait des
propositions de conciliations de
compromis ne sont jamais ou bien
s'adresse des comment dirais-je les
invitations homérique dix ans essayez
donc et vous verrez jeu dangereux
ce que je demande c'est l'équilibré
entre les forces l'équilibré stratégique
c'est-à-dire les fusées qui traverse
l'atlantique de la russie vers
l'amérique de l'amérique vers la russie
elles sont en gros équilibré et pour la
simple raison que l'un et l'autre pays
ont le moyen de se détruire là l'autre
alors pourquoi l'union soviétique at
elle décidé à partir de 1977 naît salle
et en plus ce que l'on appelle des ss 20
rapide description si vous voulez bien
pour qu'on comprenne les à 16 20 sont
des missiles judy tout à l'heure ce que
c'était difficile
t'y vas loin 4500 km avec une certaine
précision 300 m il en a combien 360 dont
puisqu'il y en a en asie dont environ
243 245 en europe pérou puisqu'il ne
traverse pas l'atlantique vers l'europe
occidentale en plus de l'équilibré
stratégique dont je le répète il existe
déjà en piste alors pourquoi est-ce pour
que l'union soviétique ça sur une
supériorité l'a déjà dans le domaine des
armes conventionnelles classique en
europe
mais telle une supériorité régionale
indiscutable veut-elle séparés dans leur
réflexe de défense les états unis
d'amérique de l'europe occidentale
enfin interrogeant les soviétiques moi
je dis ça c'est trop et j'étais monté à
la tribune de l'assemblée nationale
lorsque j'étais membre de l'opposition
pour dire crois que c'était en 1981 ni
ss20 n'y perd 6 2 j'ajoute que les 360
dont l'europe 243 ss20 sont à trois
têtes
il faut donc multiplier par 3 pour
connaître la puissance de feu c'est de
dire le nombre de charges nucléaires
alors naturellement en 1979
l'autre quand ça il s'agit des états
unis d'amérique de l'otan'' dans son
commandement intégré et la france n'y
est pas c'est donc une décision qui a
été prise sans el orden et n'avait l'air
pas à être consultés ont décidé en 1979
l'installer à son tour quatre ans plus
tard nous y sommes des missiles s qui
sont comparables c'est ce qu'on appelle
les piercings de vergy musée y croire et
les missiles de croisière parlons pour
l'instant des piercings deux qui sont
plus immédiatement comparables
au spa car du côté soviétique il ya
aussi des missiles de croisière
on distingue missiles de croisière c'est
quelque chose qui est également très
meurtriers qui est plus lent il faut 15
minutes
l'avion fait un petit avion pièce
minutes à des ss va pour parvenir à
leurs objectifs 2000 3000 4000 km csssae
et moins de 10 minutes au moins 10
minutes aux personnes de moins de 10
minutes au pershing 2 ne l'est pas
encore parlé tandis que pour les
missiles de croisière il faut plusieurs
heures
ce que vous disiez un gros avion
difficile à atteindre parce que ils
volent bas il est difficilement
perceptible par les appareils destinés à
les arrêter mais c'est très différent
donc pour limiter la conversation son
plan s'y perdre et parlons des piercings
de départ non dss vint alors le pershing
2 c'est en 1979 que la décision était
prise par l'eau tam
on a dit on va essayer de négocier mais
on décide tout de suite qu'on le fera si
la négociation région le fera pas d'où
la conférence de genève sur les oraux
missiles c'est à dire sur les forces
nucléaires dites intermédiaires et
depuis ce temps là la négociation
n'aboutit pas qu'est ce que peut faire
le perçu de caching 2 ça va moins loin
que le ss vingt mille huit cent
kilomètres c'est à dire que les
personnes de qui sera installée en
allemagne ne peut pas atteindre moscou
non il ne pourrait pas atteindre plus du
dixième des vecteurs fais des supports
d'armement nucléaire soviétique mais ils
n'ont qu'une tête aussi ses rues quand
on dit qu'il y aura 100 vite pershing
c'est le chiffre retenu par la décision
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure
108 et 464 missiles de croisière
lorsqu'on dit qu'il y aura 108e pershing
2 ça veut dire 108
quand on dit 360 ss va3 plus il faut
multiplier partout multiplication pour
243 m 3faire chose comme 729 alors le
pershing 2 et plus rapide vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure
moins de dix minutes pour atteindre cet
objectif mais
fait moins lointain sa charge est moins
puissante mais il est plus précis n'est
donc plus précis il est plus rapide
les autres qualités c'est le ss 20 qui
les a cela dit vous me disiez pourquoi
parce que les russes ont engagé cette
construction et ce déploiement de
missiles intermédiaire et je vous
répondrai vous chercher cet avantage je
pense qu'ils cherchent un avantage en
europe peut être séparée l'europe des
états unis d'amérique et les allemands
puisque c'est à la demande des allemands
que la décision de l'otan'' intégrer
j'aurais été louis
ils sont ce biais sweet a été prise la
double décision comme on dit oui à la
fois s'armer et les haussiers
cette décision qui s'applique à partir
de 1983 en angleterre pour les missiles
de croisière en allemagne pour les
perchistes 2 un peu plus tard pour
d'autres missiles de croisière cette
décision l'a fait que les deux plus
grandes puissances s'affrontent alors sa
pause
l'autre grande question qui est le refus
de la prise en compte dans les
négociations de la force nucléaire
française britannique aussi m'enfin ils
ont parents d'avoir la force nucléaire
française évidemment mais nous ne sommes
pas à genève
on ne nous a pas invité nous n'avons pas
demandé à l'être
voyez cette situation de deux pays la
russie les états unis l'amérique comme
cela face à face qui vont prendre en
compte l'armement de paix comme le nôtre
absents disposer de son armement et quel
est cet armement
c'est un point essentiel d'une
conversation et je demande qu'on s'y
arrête un instant car la france n'a pas
de force intermédiaire à la limite
législation vos images juste avant que
nous prenons les paroles à la limite il
existe 18 fusée celles qui sont au
plateau d'albion bien et qui partant du
sol français pourrait atteindre le sol
puisque vous parlez de l'union
soviétique ne sommes pas les adversaires
l'union soviétique nous n'avons pas du
tout l'intention avec quoi que ce soit
en union soviétique m'enfin
la commodité du langage et c'est en tout
cas comme cela que les soviétiques
résonne donc ses 18 là peuvent aller
d'un territoire à l'autre mais les
autres ce sont des sous marins ce sont
des sous marins nucléaires dont on a
cinq exemplaires est on en a cinq pour
l'instant et nous disposons de 80 charge
ce qui fait avec les 18 98 les anglais
en ont 64 mais sont les sous marins je
veux dire par là qu'ils peuvent circuler
partout par définition dans au dessous
de la surface de l'eau ils vont
d'ailleurs connaître des développements
qui permettront aux anglais de tirer à
7000 kilomètres de distance ce sont des
forces stratégiques qui correspondent
exactement à la définition que les
russes et les américains ont décidé
entre eux par la conséquence de la prise
en compte la titres à leur actif
à titre comparatif monsieur le président
combien lesvier de les deux
superpuissances ont-elles d'armes d'une
j allais j'y venais un instant la
conséquence de cette demande soviétique
que j'ai repoussé c'est que si nos
missiles sous marins qui peuvent faire
en effet actuellement 3500 km 4000 km
était décompté prise en compte dans la
discussion des forces intermédiaire
qu'elles ne sont pas on assisterait à ce
spectacle étrange que j'ai déjà noté
deux pays étrangers qui disposerait de
notre armement à nous cet armement et en
des sous marins alors que eux ne discute
pas de leurs sous-marins
les sous marins soviétiques et les
sous-marins américains ne sont pas dans
la discussion
puisqu'ils sont stratégiques comme les
nôtres résultat nos 98 charge du
nucléaire serait tout aussi tôt absorbé
par cette négociation particulière et en
supposant qu'elles soient gelés comme on
dit qu'est ce qui resterait monsieur
devriez c'est votre question à la france
ah que cela remet conventionnelle et
différentes âmes est d'un tout autre
ordre
qu'est-ce qui se resterait aux états
unis d'amérique environ 9000 charges
nucléaires
qu'est-ce qui se resterait à l'union
soviétique environ 9000 charge nucléaire
tout telle sorte que la comparaison
entre 9000 d'un côté et 98 de l'autre
impliquent la réponse avant de songer à
demander à la france de renoncer à son
autonomie de défense et à sa défense
tout court c'est le coeur de notre
défense que cet armement c'est la
sécurité du pays il faudrait tout le mal
que les deux grands partenaires songe à
réduire considérablement leur art alors
si vous le permettez je dois vous posez
deux ou trois questions ou plus bon que
tu allais très précises concernant
l'emploi de la force française pour
ensuite revenir à ce qui est susceptible
de débloquer la négociation
éventuellement la position que la france
y prendrait la grande négociation celle
de genève
en ce qui concerne parce qu'il faut bien
que l'arrivée je crois pour pour ceux
qui nous regardent
en ce qui concerne la force de frappe
française d'abord est ce que cette force
que vous venez de décrire la forces
nucléaires stratégiques et à dire nos
cinq sous marins le plateau d'albion et
nos avions
est-ce que son emploi théorique espérons
qu'il sera toujours théorie est ce que
son emploi théorique est exclusivement
réservée ou non à la défense du
territoire national
ou est-ce qu'il est susceptible d'emploi
par exemple par solidarité avec des pays
européens voisins
la définition retenue depuis près de 25
ans est simple elle doit être consacrée
à la défense de notre territoire à la
survie du pays à notre indépendance
nationale
hier seulement l on ajoute l on ajoute
et pour les intérêts vitaux de la france
c'est à dire qu'il appartient au
président de la république d'apprécier
si telle ou telle action extérieurs au
territoire menace directement ce
territoire
cette précision ou plutôt cette
terminologie vous pourriez dire qu'elle
manque dans cette dernière partie de
précision et celle qui a été adoptée
depuis toujours et dont on ne sort pas
absolu lorsque le président de la
république doit disposer d'une certaine
mobilité d'un certain
ils certaine liberté du site qui
signifie une certitude en ce qui
concerne le territoire national et un
point d'interrogation sélectionnés en
une guerre nos frontières cela ne peut
être que défensif dissuasif que je dis
je n'aime pas défensif dissuasif
il faut qu'on sache que notre armement
est capable de détruire un territoire
aussi vaste que du nôtre m'avoue par les
intentions du tout de nous en servir
pour attaquer qui que ce soit nous
serions fous mais nous entendons
préserver la france et je suis sûr que
les autres le comprennent parce qu'ils
sont aussi patriote mais nous n'avons
pas tout à fait finie la conversation
précédentes parce que les
téléspectateurs il faut qu'ils
comprennent pourquoi est ce que ça
montre tout le temps moi quand je dis
que je veux dit libre oui je sois à
léquilibre par le plus bas or josé 10
ans 77 décision soviétique en 79
décision de l'automne et des américains
or en 1979 monsieur brejnev avait
déclaré discute on discute en quarts
maintenant l'équilibré les réaliser
alors pourquoi ajouté ici ou là à
l'époque il y avait 63 et 16 20 en
europe pourquoi en avoir rajouté c'est à
dire beaucoup moins que maintenant
de telle sorte qu'aujourd'hui on peut
dire que la seule puissance qui
possèdent des forces nucléaires
intermédiaires qui ne traverse pas
d'entente et qu'ils peuvent pas viser
les états unis d'amérique
c'est l'union soviétique et que les
autres n'ont pas alors je me refuse tout
simplement au monopole par un p d'une
arme destructrice
alors justement là j'en arrive à la
question suivante qui est qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant pour essayer
de prévoir comment reprendre une
négociation et essayer d'arriver à une
stabilisation un équilibre et puis
ensuite peut-être une réduction
qu'est-ce qui peut y avoir comme comme
initiative imaginables et quel rôle est
ce que la france peut jouer je me
permets de vous rappeler à ce moment de
notre conversation que la france n'est
pas à jeûner pour l'instant absolument
vraiment il n'y est pas du tout
l'intention de nommer bien entendu mais
ce que je veux dire c'est pas remplies à
une hypothèse venait me dire si cette
hypothèse imaginables ou pas mais il ya
une hypothèse qui serait que si la
négociation actuelle entre les
américains et les soviétiques échoué que
dans une phase ultérieure y est par
exemple
le fusion de plusieurs négociations
c'est autre chose
je vais naturellement vous répondre
puisque je suis si pour cela mais je
tiens quand même hein ou thé observer
que la france bien qu'elle ne soit pas
parti au débat s'intéressent à la chose
c'est en europe ainsi qu un look naturel
et là des alliés qui sont concernés mais
la france n'est pas en mesure n'a pas à
faire de propositions elle dit négocier
au niveau le plus bas possible à l'heure
actuelle ils ont l'air de discuter tout
en ajoutant quelque chose dont il faut
réduire jusqu'à quel point vous étiez de
réduire jeudi jeudi devant les deux
parlements allemand je le répète un dans
d'autres circonstances négocier au plus
bas désarmement possible pour votre
sécurité
mais en préservant votre équilibre car
s'il n'ya plus équilibre entre l'un et
l'autre
alors la guerre est à nos portes
donc voila mon raisonnement vu de
l'extérieur c'est que je ne suis pas
venu puisque j'ai pas l'intention d'y
aller c'est de dire préserver en toute
circonstance l'équilibré le le jeu des
deux plus grandes puissances a été il
faut reconnaître depuis déjà quelques
mois de réduire de réduire leurs
prétentions
il ya des propositions encore très
récente qui vont dans ce sens eh ben les
dernières propositions de monsieur
andropov abouti c'est un calcul qui
exclut une partie de l'armement anglais
de l'armement française qui prouve que
il fait un geste n'est pas tout à fait
tout à fait réelle cependant il
appartient aux deux partenaires d'en
décider
on n'en est pas encore à un accord
possible
lors d'une autre négociation une autre
conférence serré ce qu'on pourrait
réunir les forces tactique on en parle
ailleurs à vienne les forces dites
intermédiaires celles qui traversent pas
la tenter celle dont on parle depuis le
début de notre conversation plus celle
dont on n'a pas beaucoup parlé mais les
efforts sont stratégiques
les 9000 soviétique et 9000 américaine
les quatre-vingt dix huit françaises les
64 anglaise et je sais pas combien dans
la
les fusées chinois hier cinq pays dans
le monde qui disposent d'un armement
nucléaire la france était un de ces 5
grand pays la voilà alors c'est une
hypothèse que j'ai examiné lorsque je me
suis adressé à l'organisation des
nations unies a pas très longtemps spa
c'était à la fin du mois de septembre et
mon jeu n'est pas rejeté l'idée nous la
france sera toujours partie prenante
lorsqu'il s'agira de parler sérieusement
de désarmement
mais j'ai ajouté il faut parler de
choses qui seraient comparables
mais les seuls chiffres que j'ai déjà
cité deux fois 9 min et 98 implique qu
avant de parler de nos 18 fusée il faut
que les deux plus grandes puissances
réduisent considérablement leur 9000
alors que le temps raison tendance à
continuer d'avril 2011 1012 mais où
est-ce que ça s'arrêtera déjà les
chinois répondu quand ils en seront à 50
% de réduction
on pourra parler je ne dirais pas la
même chose et j'ai posé d'autres
conditions se dit qu'il faut aussi que
l'on réduise le niveau des armes
classiques l'infanterie et l'artillerie
l'aviation non pas ordinaire car se
représente une réalité militaire mais or
là dessus de supériorité soviétique est
considérable il faut aussi en interdire
par accord mutuel les armes biologiques
les armes chimiques
il faut aussi en finir avec les armes
anti sous marine les armes anti 6000
antimissile les armes anti satellite
voilà des conditions que j'ai posées
il faut que ces conditions soient
retenues elles sont difficiles je le
reconnais avant que la france puisse
songer à s'engager dans cette
négociation
on essaie président vous avez changé
d'interlocuteur pour un autre quart
d'heure et pendant que marc ulmann bien
s'installer je voulais vous poser une
question en vous entendant parler de
crise la plus grave depuis cuba et
berlin je me demandais si tous les chefs
d'état sont pas tenter un jour l'autre
de dramatiser un peu la situation
extérieure pour créer le réflexe
national pour rassembler autour de leur
population pour faire taire les
dissensions les mécontentements est ce
que le parce que finalement le
la dramatisation n'est pas un moyen de
gouverner
je pense monsieur vers ie que vous ne
riez pas de moi cette idée pensé que je
pourrais m'adressant à tous les français
jouer sur leur mère est calculé sur
leurs craintes
j'ai dit tout à l'heure que si la
situation était sérieuse
la plus sérieuse après cuba 3 7 et 1962
berlin je crois que c'était 1948 que ces
deux situations avait été maîtrisé et on
doit pouvoir maîtriser celle là je veux
dire que si la conférence de genève
n'aboutit pas dans les jours qui
viennent parce que les heurts à un
accord il est vraiment serait très
imprudent d'y songer
il n'empêche que l'on doit continuer de
reprendre la capacité de dialogue et
c'est là que la france peut remplir un
rôle déterminant car elle a dit
clairement aux uns et aux autres voilà
ce que je ne veux pas mais elle est
capable de dire aussi voilà ce que je
veux
étant entendu que ce qu'elle veut
d'abord c'est que la négociation puisse
reprendre que le dialogue s'ouvre
bref qu on ouvre aussi les portes de la
paix et à cela je crois
du plus profond de moi à la condition
d'être ferme et que nul ne puisse
spéculer sur la faiblesse de l'un ou de
l'autre
alors marc ulmann pour un quart d'heure
c'est le président moi je voulais vous
interroger sur les autres points chauds
de la planète mais néanmoins cette
conversation on est arrivés m'incite à
opposer une dernière question sur ce
sujet puisque vous dites le temps presse
les déroule la négociation pratiquement
doit aboutir d'un jour à l'autre ou non
et comme les soviétiques ont annoncé
qu'en cas d'installation des fusées
pershing en europe même redoublerait la
dose ma question est la suivante de
combien de temps croyez vous qu'on
dispose encore pour relancer cette
négociation est ce l'arrivée des
piercings s leur mise en place
est ce le moment où ils seront
opérationnels bref quel est le temps qui
nous reste avant que les dés roulent ne
peut pas savoir
je pense que les responsables des deux
plus grands pays sont assez sages ces
sages c'est ea ne veulent pas la guerre
pour utiliser toutes les chances de tête
route pour voir aussi l'autre celle est
d'abord il faudra bien que chacun cède
un peu donc je ne sais pas si ce sera
dès la première installation je n'ai pas
le sentiment que cela se produise au
moment où s'installent les premiers
missiles de croisière en grande bretagne
je pense cependant que l'union
soviétique trilles un drap parole
c'est un grand pays qui a une grande
présence dans le monde vous le savez et
dont le prestige doit être respectée car
à paroles c'est de dire que la partir
d'un certain moment qui pourrait être
l'installation réel du premier père
chine de la première des piercings en
allemagne je pense que l'union
soviétique qui tu râles la conférence de
genève comme cela a été dit par monsieur
andropov mais je ne pense pas je ne veux
pas le penser et la france usera de tous
ses moyens pour que cela ne soit pas
possible je ne pense pas que la rupture
soit durable parce que les uns et les
autres en ont besoin après tout l'union
soviétique n'a pas tellement besoin
d'avoir beaucoup de vcs 20
supplémentaires elle regorge d'armes et
tous les objectifs européens peuvent
déjà être atteint
à l'exception de ceux qui disposent
d'une force de dissuasion
et puis je crois que les dirigeants
soviétiques sont des gens qui ont
favorisé le sens naturellement des
intérêts de leurs peuples
c'est comme un peuple qui a eu 20
millions de morts à la dernière guerre
ils ont besoin d'une restauration peut
employer ce terme de leur économie
non je crois vraiment que un pays comme
la france peut être utile dans cette
phase il a dit ce qu'il avait à dire au
moment du plus grand danger c'est à dire
tu refus opposé à des solutions force de
compromis qui intéressait mon pays d'une
façon inadmissible mais nous sommes les
adversaires de personnes
et je compte bien intervenir de la façon
la plus utile qu'ils soient et selon les
conceptions dans le moment qui me
paraîtra nécessaire je parie donc vous
parlez donc de l' équilibre nécessaire
en europe mais en deux qu'est ce que
vous craignez au juste l'expansionnisme
soviétique sur l'europe où un feu aux
poudres qui serait mis par des
étincelles survenant ailleurs par
exemple au moyen-orient la kz2 tout le
débat
c'est quand même les euromissiles je ne
la quitte pas du tout l'union soviétique
de vouloir se lancer dans cette guerre
j'avais déjà plusieurs fois répété mais
de se mettre dans une situation de force
qui fasse que en somme par l'exercice de
la menace elles obtiennent les résultats
que l'on obtient l'ordinaire d'une
guerre veillée il a donc à l'aspect
psychologique très important dans cette
affaire
rester en europe et de loin les plus
forts sans que les américains
interviennent
bref les recherches qu'on appelle le
découplage est encore en ces mots plus
compliqué à comprendre ce que veut dire
la séparation des intérêts d'europe
occidentale et des intérêts américains à
partir du mans il n'y aurait plus qu'un
dialogue
les soviétiques union soviétique et les
européens occidentaux
il resterait que la france ait nourri
terre avec leurs 98 leur 64 pourrait-il
être considéré comme chargé de garder
l'europe toute entière
soyons raisonnables puis à côté tous les
autres points chauds comme monty qui
s'allument un peu partout entretenu ici
et là en attendant que la grande
discussions de genève finissent pas
rapporter un résultat est quelquefois
dépendant de cette situation étant
entendu qu aussitôt chacune des deux
plus grandes puissances se fait ce qu'il
faut pour que les choses durera cinq
noms reviennent à l'épreuve
de force diplomatique qui se déroule à
genève dans les meilleures conditions
jugées par l'un ni par l'autre dans le
sens de leurs intérêts pendant la
situation au liban par exemple qu'est ce
que vous craignez le plus que la france
soit entraînée dans une intervention que
lancerait les américains et les
israéliens ou pensez vous craignez vous
au contraire que les soldats français se
retrouve tout seul en cas de départ des
américains
je ne pense pas que la question puisse
se poser dans ces termes savait que la
france y est allé à la demande du
gouvernement libanais c'était je crois
le 19 septembre 1982 il a fait appel à
plusieurs particulier la france et la
france est arrivé tout de suite dès le
21 et à quoi a servi le contingent
français a sauvé la vie de centaines et
de centaines de palestiniens qui se
trouvaient écrasés sous les
bombardements de beyrouth ouest et que
nous avons
sinon à rapatrier du moins dirigées vers
un autre pays arabe en l'occurrence sur
quoi pour l'essentiel la tunisie nos
soldats ont donc déjà servi non pas la
cause de ces combattants s'était pas du
tout la nôtre c'est à dire avec l'accord
du gouvernement israélien de force
d'interposition en empêcher qu'on se
déchire et qu'on tue davantage une
grande cause qu'est notre mission était
remplie on est parti et a su se sont
déroulées les massacres de sabra et de
chatila
nous avons dû revenir et c'était
compréhensible elle est revenue et c'est
depuis cette époque que nous avons avec
les américains d'une part les italiens
d'autre part et d'une certaine façon les
anglais une force me dit multinationale
où sont présentées ces quatre pays étant
entendu que chacune des forces au pays
au seul commandement de saad de son pays
de sa nationalité et de ses forces les
américaines et les français ont été
attaqués récemment et ils vont le sait
bien et qu'elle
d'envisager des représailles l'usagé
pour ce que ce que vous le dira d'abord
je pense ses contenus dans votre
question c'est puisque les choses ont
changé est ce que nos forces continuent
d'avoir une émission là bas leur mission
telle qu'elle est estimé par le
gouvernement libanais légitime reconnu
par tous par la france naturellement et
par la plupart des libanais qu'ils ont
exprimé récemment après le drame de cet
immeuble effrontées ou cinq en plus des
nôtres son bord c'est de dire que la
france tradition historique devoir à
l'égard d'un peuple d'une culture le
liban et la france c'est une vieille et
grande histoire
je suis porteur de ne plus qu'une
tradition d'intérêt des intérêts
légitimes de grand intérêt
je ne peux pas signer je me refuserai la
disparition de la france de la surface
du globe en dehors de son pré carré
dès lors que cela représente d comme
tirage d'une internationl justifié à la
fois sur le plan humanitaire et aussi
sur le plan politique alors les missions
d'aujourd'hui elle reste d'occuper la
zone de beyrouth qui nous a été confiée
par le gouvernement libanais et d'y
assurer ce que font nos soldats n'ira
blement la sécurité nos soldats sont
tout à la fois un infirmier gardiens
gardiennes ap il aide le lait les vieux
il sauve le jeune il toutes ses
petits-enfants qu'on va courir par les
rues soûles et sous les obus
parmi la mitraille nous sommes
interviennent chaque fois pour sauver
des 1
c'est pour ça qu'on les appelait les
soldats la paix mais en même temps ils
représentent la froide la france dans
une action qu'on ne considère comme très
importante pour la france
alors quelle solution par rapport à
cette mission
j'ai bien entendu n'ont pas l'intention
d'y rester et c'est pourquoi nous avons
beaucoup poussé à la réconciliation
nationale des libanais de cette
réconciliation du foie réalisée
nous n'avons pas à nous attarder
davantage au liban on peut imaginer
aussi un statut garantit par
puissances intéressées les puissances de
la région les puissances intéressées
celles qui ont des troupes là-bas on
peut imaginer
l'intervention des nations unies qui ont
déjà une force dans le sud du liban qu
on appelle la finul depuis 1978 vous
disiez vous même monsieur le président
que tant que ces affaires de romy s'ils
ne sont pas réglés certaines puissances
garde si je puis dire des crises au
chaud donc comment sp levant cette
réconciliation nationale alors que les
syriens donc muni d'une façon des
soviétiques ont quand même leur mot à
dire notre identité mais enfin il faut
quand même reconnaître aux pays voisins
du liban et aux dépens lui même qui
comporte beaucoup de patriotes dans
toutes les tendances
une certaine capacité à échapper à la
toute puissance des deux plus grands
aucune chance existe un accord local
garanti par une institution
internationale
en tout cas nous serons là tant que ce
service devrait être remplie avec les
intentions de contribuer au retour à la
concorde civile et bien entendu à
rapatrier tout aussitôt nos soldats mais
nous aviez poser une autre question tout
à l'heure à propos de dramatique
assassinat de nos 58 soldats tandis que
250 soldats américains à quelques
encablures se trouve être eux-mêmes
abattu non monsieur là ne ce crime ne
resterait pas impuni mais j'ai par
exemple pour eux maintenant tu reviens
là dessus mais finalement vous dites ce
crime ne restera pas impuni c'est à dire
qu'on fait
vous envisagez et que les américains
peuvent envisager de leur côté des
actions sur le terrain tout ce qui
touche à la légitime défense représente
un droit fondamental de l'homme
je vous parlais d'un droit fondamental
de l'homme je me servir si fiers de
cette transition
les américains sont intervenus à 1 conad
vous personnellement le gouvernement
français en tout cas a critiqué cette
intervention parlant du droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes mais il
existe des carmes semble-t-il où il se
trouve
les gouvernement à écraser leurs peuples
jeudi à des gouvernements qui ne sont
pas forcément tendre et dans le cas de
grenade ce général dont j'ai oublié le
nom et qui avait renversé le président
légitime n'était pas probablement un
amour fou des droits de l'homme
il faudrait avoir toutes les pièces du
dossier en main ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que je connaissais ce qui choque
il est le président que si nos résidents
assassiné je n'ai reçu également à paris
je vais rencontrer d'autre part et il
m'avait déjà confié sa crête voir un
débarquement s'opérer dans son île
c'était donc avant les événements qui
ont suivi et je savais d'autre part que
bien que ami très proche de cuba ou bien
parce que ami très proche de cuba
il n'avait pas du tout l'intention
d'affronter les états unis d'amérique et
il recherchait un mode easy lundi comme
on dit tenir un arrangement
et puis en fait qui moi aussi j'ai réagi
c'est particulier la france est un pays
indépendant
si je m'adresse à l'union soviétique en
lui reprochant certains actes ce que je
n'hésite pas à faire soit distance sur
les actions en pologne bien voter encore
à faire de la région sud coréen la
position dans la sphère des euromissiles
je m'adresse aux américains
chaque fois qu'il me semble qu'il
complique l'equilibre internationale ou
bien tout simplement qu'il ne respecte
pas les droits fondamentaux sur lequel
repose la société internationale ce qui
accroît constamment les risques de
conflits et le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes elle ne convient
pas aux états unis d'amérique le soin
d'être les arbitres de ce qui se passe à
grenade non mais des fois d'autres
moyens mais des fois il y aussi non
assistance à peuple en danger non non
non
on ne pense pas quels que soient les
sentiments que je puisse avoir pour les
américains des sentiments d'amitié même
si je conteste souvent leur politique en
la circonstance
non ils n'ont pas été chargé de cela et
ce serait trop commode que de s'ériger
en gendarmes sur la surface de la terre
non ce n'est pas possible on ne peut pas
remettre l'existence des pays y compris
le nôtre à la disposition d'un seul qui
s'estimeraient m d'intervenir quand cela
d'une part il me paraîtrait coïncidé
avec l'idée qu'il se fait disons de
l'assistance à personne en danger mais
peut-être aussi de la défense de ses
propres intérêts vue d'une façon un peu
étroites ou dangereuses donc nous avons
j'ai condamné l'intervention des états
unis d'amérique à grenade comme j'ai
déploré leur politique dans toute façon
générale en amérique centrale
j'ai expliqué moi même à monsieur reagan
lorsque je suis allé voir à washington
l'année dernière c'était l'objet l'un
des objets particuliers de mon voyage
mon voyage éclair et essai en 24 heures
je lui ai expliqué que je pense que
c'était de comprendre tout de travers le
problème de ces peuples qui ont besoin
d'être libéré libéré des oligarchies qui
les écrasent kharchi financière
la grande propriété et disons de la
domination militaire au dictatorial qui
s'ensuit le monde occidental qui est
porteur de grande valeur doit comprendre
et aider ces peuples à retrouver leur
liberté leur liberté économique social
et politique
bon alors voilà voilà pourquoi j'estime
que dans ces cas là je n'ai pas à
approuver et j'ai parfois condamnés
c'est ça l'indépendance de la france on
dit quelquefois que c'est incohérent
mais la cohérence de la politique dont
j'ai assumé la responsabilité c'est
partout la dépendance de nos actions et
l'indépendance de notre jugement me vire
yongxing que j'ai plus droit qu'à une
question
et puisque vous parlez de l'indépendance
de notre jugement dans l'est de la
france bien entendu ma question est est
ce que vous ne croyez pas que le temps
est venu aussi de faire entendre la voix
de l'europe en tant qu'europe parce que
vous avez parlé des euromissiles comme
le point central si je puis dire
les incertitudes des dangers qui nous
menacent donc l'europe est concernée en
tant que tel dans beaucoup de points du
monde nous sommes amenés à intervenir
mais au fond la france s'est un peu
l'europe quand on la regarde de loin et
comment croyez vous surtout que
maintenant en un chancelier allemand qui
est certain ça fait de moi un européen
qui est un disciple du vieil adenauer
mais qui peut-être bien le seul dans son
pays je veux dire à dresde et vous
n'auriez pas ce n'est pas le seul à le
dire il
comment profiter si je puis dire de sa
présence comment faire pour que l'europe
existe en tant que telle ou existe
plutôt est ce que vous comprenez dans
votre raisonnement
l'idée d'une défense commune européenne
je le comprenais dans mon raisonnement
mais c'est un c'est à vous de répondre
parce que moi parce que non monsieur x
men pour pouvoir avoir une heure et bien
sûr est complète
parce que si vous aviez cela dans
l'esprit que je vous parle de moi des
bourdaines à l'école qui ne sont pas
normales et dans la cheminée agricole
audrey centre est effectivement sur vous
dites rééquilibrage des forces nos
caisses qu'on fait à l'abri de ce
rééquilibrage des forces qui n'est pas
une fin en soi
quelle europe militaire construisons
nous ménage avait 2 2 il est en fait
celle là que vient d'exprimer virieu et
celle aussi quand vous dites j'exprime
mon opinion sur que je ne sais pas
grenade la veille est ce que l'europe ne
peut pas exprimer son opinion
vous avez raison vous avez raison
l'europe est la grande d'europe
occidentale ce qu'on appelle leur offre
multimédia et la grande vaincus de la
dernière guerre et la haine disparaît
vue en tant que tel
futur en tant que telle n'a jamais
existé vraiment tant que tel mais elle a
représenté une forme d'expression de
civilisation de puissance qui s'y est
elle avait été associée ces nations qui
se disputait souvent qui se sont
déchirés dans des guerres civiles qui
leur est accordé une plus grande
puissance encore en fait c'était quand
même
l'europe qui se trouvait à la tête du
mouvement général des affaires quand ce
n'était pas du mouvement général
d'hésiter alors naturellement on pense
aujourd'hui après cette dure épreuve
cette disparition de tant de force et de
valeur derrière
sur le plan militaire la puissance
américaine la puissance soviétique
sur le plan économique
sans ces américaines puissant japonaises
ont sens commun comme un mal en soi un
mal d'europe et je suis tout à fait prêt
à comprendre ce qu'ils disent eh bien
peut-être s'organise économiquement
politiquement ce sera le sujet de la
conférence que j'aurais à atteindre
bientôt du sommet européen qui est assez
difficile et même très difficile et
c'est le sujet traité par beaucoup de
responsables politiques importants dans
notre vie intérieure ne risquerez pas
une idée de défense européenne pourquoi
ce qu'on associerait pas les moyens les
moyens économiques industrielles les
moyens d' inventions de création les
laines les moyens de la plus grande
puissance commerciale du monde qui est
quand même l'europe occidentale et qui
ne se traduit pas en force politique et
qui se traduit pas toujours en force
économique car on traite avec ceux ci on
traite avec cela on donne la préférence
à ceux qui se trouvent de l'autre côté
de la terre puis tout est allé chercher
son voisin et même sur le plan des armes
monsieur le masne on achète des
armements en commande des armements à
d'autres pays qu'à ceux de l'europe âme
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas de
désarmement qui soit harmonisée c'est
dire que nous sommes loin de compte il
faut que l'europe d'abord exprime soit
capable d'exprimer une volonté politique
il faut ensuite qu'elle surmonte un
certain nombre d'obstacles importants
qui sont nées de la dernière guerre
mondiale et qui font que l'allemagne
dispose d'un statut particulier qui lui
interdire certains développements
militaires notamment sur le plan
nucléaire bien la conséquence de la
guerre l'union soviétique est très
vigilante sur ce plan n'est pas la seule
la défense européenne
c'est une idée dont je comprends à la
force
jouable en soi qui doit donner un
objectif important à tous les
responsables politiques de l'europe
occidentale à condition d'avancer avec
sagesse pour éviter de bâtir sur du
sable ou au contraire de préparer des
explosions nouvelle
6 et la coupure définitive de l'europe
en deux renvoyer les uns comme ça
définitivement à l'est et nous nous
comptons mener sur l'ouest
bon entre eux mais il faut penser à cela
bref je pense qu'il faut sortir du
partage de yalta et jeudi ya déjà bien
longtemps
en tout cas solennellement après mon
élection à la présidence de la
république
mais il faut en même temps savoir que
cela ne se fera pas sans déchirement
sans préparation sans une approximation
presque scientifique de l'esprit gardons
cette idée préparons l'échéance une
volonté politique pour l'europe dominons
des débats à petit aujourd'hui nous en
pêtre et dans lequel on risque de se
perdre
et quand cette démonstration sera faite
y compris sur le plan devrait peut-être
désarmement on peut on pourra imaginer
peut-être dès maintenant des stratégies
complémentaires
déjà la france remplit ce rôle elle
remplit ce rôle car c'est moi même qui a
ranimé le traité de l'elysée signé par
le général de gaulle et monsieur
adenauer en 1963 y ait des tentes en vie
un article oublié qui permet de discuter
avec l'état-major de l'allemagne de
l'ouest dit j'ai également engager des
conversations militaire avec les
responsables de la grande bretagne
nous disposons en allemagne d'une force
d'intervention ou d'action rapide qui
jouerait son rôle dans le cadre d'un
conflit
s'il devait y en avoir un mais je le
répète je ne peux pas distribuer la
décision qui m'appartient à moi seul en
france mais aussi kim appartiendrait à
moi seul en europe de disposer d'une
force nucléaire qui ne peut être que de
dissuasion de dissuasion pour la france
et pour les intérêts vitaux que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure mais qui ne peut
pas prétendre assurer la naissance de
l'europe
voilà je demande simplement que cette
idée soit retenue mais qu'on avance et
sagement le président nous allons
maintenant nous tourner vers svp où je
crois questions sont traitées nombreuses
alors philippe harrouard avez vous des
premières questions
oui monsieur le président
un thème souvent abordés par les
téléspectateurs et pour vous en parler
je prendrai la question d'un étudiant
denis ce monsieur sommaire qui vous dis
ceci comment la france peut-elle
concilier son désir de paix et son rôle
de vendeur d'armes
la france a en effet bâti une puissante
industrie d'armement
d'abord pour pouvoir soutenir son propre
armement et le marché français ne
seraient pas suffisants pour justifier
des usines tournent
car on ne pourrait pas rentabiliser
cette action donc les gouvernements
précédents un groupe décision qui
remonte à la fin de la guerre d'algérie
il faudra vu ça remonte à très loin a
longtemps avant mode élections ont
engagé une politique d'armement qui a
abouti d'ailleurs sur ce plan là une
grande réussite industrielle et donc à
des ventes importantes d'armes ses
ventes sont en diminution
peut-être de 25% 1983 par rapport à 1982
ce qui n'a d'ailleurs pas altérer notre
commerce extérieur qui comme vous savez
est en progrès d'une année sur l'autre
donc nous sommes nous vendons en effet
des âmes le problème pour nous et
d'hésiter d'alimenter les lieux où se
déroulent des combats pourraient dire
que je me trouve en contradiction sur ce
point dans un seul cas celui de
l'acquéreur l'irak et l'iran
nous en parlerons si vous le voulez bien
je pense que pour assurer le changement
d'orientation de la politique
industrielle de la france dans une
époque où malheureusement le chômage est
un mâle nationale et internationale il
faut préparer des reconversions
industrielles et cela prend du temps
voilà ce que je répondrai à sept
étudiants étant bien entendu que je
comprends très bien la raison morale et
politique qui n'inspire une autre
question philippe harrouard danse d'une
question qui a trait à ce que vous avez
dit au début de votre
intervention c'est à dire les problèmes
de défense et de guerre il y a un très
très grand nombre de téléspectateurs qui
sont certainement très pratique car ils
nous demandent pourquoi n'y at-il pas
d'abris antiatomiques de prévu pour la
population on nous dit aussi la suisse
est pourvue d'abris antiatomiques qu'en
est il pour la france avez-vous pensé à
sauvegarder la population civile en cas
de conflit il ya 70 appels sur ce thème
est d'ailleurs ce qui est très
intéressant c'est de voir que la
majorité des gens qui nous appellent
sont des gens qui habitent dans les
villes ils ont raison de se poser la
question
j'observerai cependant que pour les pays
possesseurs détenteur d'une arme d'une
armée nucléaire dont l'objet est
essentiellement de dissuader toute
agression
notre stratégie repose sur l'idée et la
réalité qu'on ne peut pas nous attaquer
sans subir de tels dommages que l'enjeu
ne voudrais pas la peine bon alors c'est
vrai que la protection civile comme on
dit les abris en particulier est passé
depuis 25 ans en arrière plan cela m'a
inquiété lors d'un récent un comité de
défense
c'est un sujet qui peut être traitée en
public puisqu'on me pose la question je
vais l'aborder
j'ai demandé que chaque fois que nous
entreprendrons des grands travaux et
constructions et serait nécessaire de
prévoir la défense civile c'était une
réponse tout à fait partielles un
problème immense qui représenterait un
financement considérable mais voici le
point où nous en sommes notre défense
passive n'est pas suffisante il faut
engager mais avec les moyens qu'on a
il faut engager une action de
construction d'abris mais savoir que
nous sommes un pays qui possède une arme
nucléaire capable de repousser les
ambitions d'un adversaire se présente
nous retenons tout à l'heure à sp pour
l'instant les questions d' albert du roy
j'ai président tout à l'heure en parlant
de là
de l'attentât meurtrier commis contre
des soldats français et américain à
beyrouth
vous avez en détachant vos mots dits cet
acte ne restera pas impuni à qui vous
adressez vous à qui je m'adressais
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur les commanditaires de ces attentats
enfin monsieur du roi jeu merci aux
français et comme ce qui se dit ici
n'est pas ignorée dans le reste du monde
ceux qui ont procédé à cet attentat
savent qu'ils subiront la loi d'un
châtiment justifié c'est tout je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire mais c'est moi
demeurez responsable de mes décisions
d'abord nous invite à propos du liban
vous avez tout récemment rendu hommage
yasser arafat que pensez vous de la
situation dramatique dans lequel lui et
ses partisans se trouve je n'ai pas la
poisse et je dirais comme vous sans
doute mais pas encore dit qu'il est très
mauvaise que en quelques mois la
situation de noël paix qui suit monsieur
arafat s'est extraordinairement
dégradées ne représente plus la force
que nous connaissions dans les années
précédentes
si je me suis exprimé à ce sujet c'est
tout à la fois sur le plan disons
humanitaires et sur le plan politique
sur le plan du jeu c'est une sentiments
humains normaux voire al ahly dans un
pays arabe par les arabes par des
dissidents de même mouvement en même
temps que par des pays voisins détruire
ccco gens qui courent après une patrie
qu'on en face d'un endroit à l'autre et
que l'on tue c'est toujours des scouts
et là on s'adresse lorsqu'on veut tuer
quelqu'un dans cette région du monde
je dis non c'est un ce n'est pas
supportable et la france ne doit pas
s'associer même par le verbe à des
actions de ce genre
mais j'ajoute que sur le plan politique
il faudra bien aborder le problème du
peuple palestinien
le sud n'ont pas reprendre une vieille
explications qui nous attarderai car
vous savez quel point je suis sensible à
la défense des droits du droit à
l'existence d'israël
mais je continue de penser que israël et
les autres ou tort de ne pas penser à
ces cinq millions de gens et rang et qui
représente un peuple intelligent et
courageux
pourquoi les pouvoirs syrien s'en
prend-il actuellement nous en sommes
réduits aux interprétations je pense que
les syriens qui n'ont jamais reconnu
l'existence du liban qui considère que
cela fait partie de la grande syrie ne
veulent pas de concurrent il ya un
conflit dans lequel la france est
engagée à la demande du gouvernement
légitime de ce pays et dont nous n'avons
pas encore parlé dans cette émission
c'est le tchad
dès le début de l'opération de
l'intervention française en août dernier
certains avaient craint un enlisement
est-ce que actuellement nous sommes
enlisés ou est ce qu'il y à des
mouvements diplomatique par exemple qui
permettrait d'envisager une solution à
ce problème du tchad
qu'est ce qu'on appelle land is mans
dans quelles conditions la france at
elle envoyé des troupes au tchad
le français au tchad a fait des
expériences les plus diverses et les
plus contradictoires en 1969 jusqu'en
1972 on a fait une guerre au tchad et
nos adversaires c'était monsieur
goukouni et monsieur hissène habré on a
fait une guerre en rase campagne
et quand on est parti trois ans après
c'était la même chose même désordre la
même concurrence des clans la même
guerre civile alimentée par des intérêts
étrangers
bon alors je dis ça suffit à un peu plus
tard en 1976 on a signé un traité avec
le gouvernement du tchad en lisant des
saignements
nous ça nous intéressait plus on s'en
aller on n'intervenait plus on est
revenu en 1978 à la demande du
gouvernement du tchad
je crois que c'était le même que celui
qu'avait suscitée par le maître c'était
en gros le même ça et puis en 1980 le
chef du gouvernement saad
j'ai beaucoup n'y a appelé les libyens à
l'aide
et libyens sont venus et les soldats
français sont partis en estimant qu'il
n'avait pas sur les ordres de métier a
demandé au gouvernement des poc ne vais
pas se mêler des affaires du chan et
c'est comme cela que lorsque moi j'ai
été élu président de la république la
totalité du tchad était dans les mains
de la libye
qui donc sur l'autorité du président de
monsieur kadhafi
monsieur kadhafi qui est l'animateur que
vous savez de l'inde rita et de la
révolution libyenne la libye était
devenu voisine d'un certain nombre de
pays d'afrique noire avec une capacité
de pénétration et de déstabilisation de
l'ensemble de l'afrique mois lorsque les
événements du même ordre se sont
produits après que vice obtenu de
monsieur roux connu le départ des
libyens mais la guerre civile a repris
monsieur goukouni à du parti me suis
sabre est devenu chef de l'état du tchad
après une victoire militaire de nouveau
l'intervention de la libye et le tchad
s'est trouvé en passe d'être à nouveau
occupée par les armées de ce pays
mais j'ai reçu monsieur du roi
d'intervention de 7,8 10 ce pays
d'afrique noire qui sont venus vers la
france en dix ans mais certains d'entre
nous avons des accords de défense avec
vous c'est un danger pour nous tous
on ne peut pas accepter que un état
africain père de son intégrité
si l'on redonne la parole aux ethnies
c'est tout l'équilibré africains qui
explose la france un doigt et oui la
france a droit et j'ai décidé
d'intervenir sur le tchad vous apparaît
utile dans les situations présent c'est
à dire le tchad qui se trouve centre sud
mitoyen des pays d'afrique toi ton char
le chat peut plus
il y a quatre millions trois cent mille
habitants dans le chatt contrôlé par les
forces françaises il y en a 150 milles
dans le tchad occupée par les forces
libyennes mais naturellement c'est une
ligne de démarcation purement militaire
doit être provisoire car l'objectif
recherché
c'est le retour à l'intégrité du tchad
et pour cela nous avons tous les
soutiens de tous aussi bien de ceux
qu'on appelle les progressistes et joppy
de l'algérie que de ce qu'on appelle les
modérés la côte d'ivoire ou bien le
gabon bien sénégal tous alors nous avons
dit ce problème doit être réglé par
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
c'est elle que cela regarde tout ce dont
nous parlons tous ces leaders politiques
et tous ses états appartiennent à
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
c'est pour l'instant le président de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine qui
est le président de l'ethiopie ainsi que
secrétaire général de l'unité africaine
qui s'occupe de ce dossier bien entendu
on n'a pas laissé tomber et nous hâtons
le moment c'est ce qu'on a fait à vittel
où monsieur hissène habré et les autres
se rencontreront pour décider en commun
du sort de leur pays en dehors de
présence de toute armée étrangère y
compris de la nôtre je n'attend que le
moment où cela sera rendu possible avec
le négociations ayant abouti à la
sauvegarde de l'intégrité territoriale
du tchad
les soldats français partiront tout
aussitôt ils n'ont à se mêler à aucune
aventure coloniale
est-ce que vous avez fixé de limite dans
le temps j'ai bien bonne idée là dessus
vous venez parler du devoir de la france
en afrique où elles devoir de la france
de la france dans le conflit iran irak
auquel vous avez fait allusion doute à
l'heure il quelles sont les raisons qui
ont fait que la france a en livrant des
super étendard à l'irak semblait choisir
son camp mais c'est du roi moi je suis
levé rick et des grands choix de la
france
en réformer certains lorsqu'ils me
paraît est naturellement tout à fait
contraire ce que je crois ce qui me
paraît utile pour la france mais à
priori le fait que depuis 1975 975
l'irak soit le premier client en achats
d'armes
sauf quoi pendant des années où ça a été
l'arabie saoudite dans le monde
l'aca d'armes françaises dans le monde
c'est une situation que j'ai trouvé que
je n'ai pas retrouvé
mais savez vous que nous en sommes
encore à liserés des avions mirage
s'ils ont été commandés en 1979 mais
savez vous que les ce qu'on appelle et
super étendard
ce sont des avions qui n'ont pas tout à
fait le rayon d'action et la puissance
des virages de telle sorte que si ça
n'avait pas été des super étendard
ça aurait été des virages et les
contrats courent depuis maintenant huit
ans et nous les avons renouvelé ou
accrue depuis 1982-83 c'est là peut être
question se pose tout à fait pourquoi
eh bien oui nous avons continué d'aider
notre ami et nous les dons pour le je
crois pour le tiers de son armement car
c'est l'union soviétique et l'ensemble
des pays de l'est qui fournissent les
deux tiers de l'armement un soviétique
j'ai souvent répondu à nos questions
composé d'environ 10 à écouter lire en
hausse ils achètent des armes et à qui
donc il y a des gens qui fournissent des
armes
alliant des gens qui fournissent des
armes ira très des gens qui fournissent
des armes à l'iran et à l'irak
j'en aurai pas la liste c'est pas le cas
de la france devrait revenir et ne
sommes pas les ennemis d'hier ans et je
n'ai pas du tout l'intention de forcer
la note
j'ai rempilé contrat j'ai renouvelé ce
qui paraissait st l'irak est un pays ami
mais je n'entends pas que notre vente
d'armes puisse être assimilé à un acte
d'agression
étant entendu que l'iran serait pendu en
de nombreuses menaces qui ne
m'impressionne pas
mais qui risquent de détourner la
situation de son sens la france n'a pas
choisi son camp il se trouve qu'elle a
une amitié elle ne veut pas avoir un
ennemi devrait revenir au problème de la
défense par un autre aspect qui n'a pas
encore été abordé ce soir qui est celui
du pacifisme vous connaissez le slogan
mieux vaut rouge que morts c'est à dire
mieux vaut perdre sa liberté que de
courir le risque nucléaire est ce que
vous pensez que l'esprit de capitulation
est très répandue en france je ne parle
pas des militants pacifistes parle de
l'opinion publique en général tu te
crois pas non je ne crois pas je crois
que la position de la france que j'ai
exprimés hautement reçoit l'approbation
d'une grande majorité de français
non je ne crois pas dans cette affaire
du pacifisme de toi je distingue
je distingue ceux qui par nature par
tradition par conviction estime que tout
armement surtout à l'échelle de
l'armement nucléaire que sa capacité de
destruction est détestable et doit être
immédiatement et par principe repousser
sa célébrer pacifiste il ya ceux qui
sont sensibles à des propagandes
extérieur souvent sans s'en rendre
compte associer déjà un peu moins net
et puis dans les autres pays que la
france dans l'est autre pays que la
france
ceux qui n'ont pas d'armement nucléaire
et qui sont exaspérés d'avoir sur leur
sol des explosifs tels que leur pays
peut sauter et que ces explosifs soit à
la disposition d'un piqué amis sans
doute mais étranger veut dire les états
unis car ils n'ont pas mal s'ils sont
consultés ils n'ont pas la possibilité
de prendre une décision
ils n'ont pas comme on dit la double clé
c'est pas eux qui sont maîtres de cet
armement
alors je suppose que dans ce refus
d'esprit national qui quelquefois peut
devenir nationaliste s'ajoute un flot de
pacifistes nouveau seulement voyez-vous
quand l'union soviétique en 1977 a
installé ses premiers essais sva c'était
le moment pour des pacifistes de se
rassembler
puisque c'était le moment où en dehors
de l' équilibre mondial ou sans doute
qui avait-il le système avancé comme on
dit d amérique et en europe mais les
décisions soviétiques ont toujours été
prise préalablement c'était le moment
d'engager une grande campagne est de
rejoindre ou deux coups sûrs avec moi le
cri que ces poussées en 1981 ni piercing
2 ni à 16 20 ensuite deux ans trois ans
quatre ans plus tard c'était plus tard
trop tard
c'est à dire que à ce moment là c'était
demandé aux pays occidentaux d'arrêter
tout d'un coup les frais de geler la
situation
la situation en déséquilibre et si l'on
veut bien se souvenir que la politique
française repose sur cette notion
fondamentale de mme équilibre des forces
dans le monde est devenu meilleur
équilibre possible plus bas en europe
alors on se rendre compte que je les la
situation dans le déséquilibre avec une
horde présence de missiles les
soviétiques et l'absence d'autres
missiles intermédiaire en europe
notamment américains s'était cristallisé
une situation dont serait sorti de la
guerre voilà pourquoi je pense que le
pacifique se trompent quant à la méthode
et ce n'est pas possible si lady à
bruxelles d'admettre un tel raisonnement
pour l'instant il ya peut-être des gens
qui a sûrement des gens qui veulent la
paix en union soviétique
mais pour l'instant on développe
l'armement et à l'ouest on développe le
pacifisme cela n'est pas égale donc je
ne la cuisse personnes se dit simplement
que dans ma responsabilité dans ma
responsabilité qui est la responsabilité
suprême en france et cette
responsabilité
elle n'est pas réduite à néant dans le
reste du monde et particulièrement en
europe se dit non cela n'est pas
possible il faut que chacun assume son
devoir et le devoir actuelle c'est de
préserver un équilibre des forces entre
eux ceux d'ici et ceux qui sont là je ne
sortirai pas
de cette règle d'or dans ces deux règles
il y a deux solidarité sur lesquels vous
devriez pouvoir compter il est d'une
part la solidarité interne à votre
majorité gouvernementale or on sait que
les communistes ne partage pas votre
vision des choses
il a d'autre part la solidarité de
l'internationale socialiste
or beaucoup de sociaux démocrates
européens on vient encore de le voir ces
derniers jours à strasbourg ne suivent
pas la même ligne politique que vous est
ce que ces deux désaccord ne nuisent pas
à la force de votre politique
je ne crois pas je ne le crois pas sur
le plan de la politique intérieure
française
d'abord prend pas qu'on puisse
simplifiée en disant ceci ils sont
contre pas surtout qu'en face c'est vrai
que des des opinions divergentes ont été
exprimées je ne m'en occupe pas ma
responsabilité c'est la mienne je le dis
sans présomption c'est la responsabilité
de ma fonction c'est mon devoir vis à
vis de la france est trop pardon même
des institutions
j'agis dans ma réflexion
je saisis le gouvernement jean débat
avec le premier ministre et les
ministres intéressés
le cas échéant lorsqu'il ya une matière
végétative ou un débat le parlement les
saisies mais ce n'est pas mon affaire
que de savoir de quelle façon agissent
tel et tel parti je décide et je choisis
et le reste s'organiser se déterminent
autour de cette décision
rien ne fera changer lamielle la
première phrase et les socialistes des
autres pays par les socios socialistes
et socio-démocrates des autres pays
généralement ils sont pas au pouvoir ce
qui s'exprime ainsi est il était souvent
pas toujours lorsqu'ils ont décidé
d'implanter des armes nucléaires
l'enveloppé mais fataliste il ya un
certain manque de logique dans cette
attitude mais aussi sans aucun doute une
une conviction sincère nous en débattons
souvent mais je pense que les français
et leurs amis européens ont là un beau
sujet de débat sans que personne ne se
jettent l'anathème
mais moi mes décisions ne peuvent pas
tenir à de telles considérations la
première apparition la première phase
que vous avez prononcé dans cette
émission et le président a été la pièce
maîtresse de la défense de la france
c'est moi oui enfin vous comptez y
compris ce que je vous le dis absolument
je veux dire simplement que lorsque tout
repose sur la dissuasion
c'est à dire sur le fait que nul ne
puisse douter de la volonté du chef de
l'état qui décide
à ce moment là la dissuasion est plein
et entier et le monde entier nous
respecte voilà pourquoi je j'ai aussi
devoir de m'adresser à l'opinion en
disant je dois m'exprimer je dois dire
ce que je veux faire je dois m'expliquer
je doit éclairer ce qui peut paraître
confus je doit engager les français sur
un chemin qui est souvent difficile qui
exige du courage de la résolution de
l'effort mais la cause vaut la peine
c'est celle de la france ssl je le crois
d'une civilisation que j'aime et que je
sais alors justement ma question dépasse
un peu votre fonction vous êtes donc
l'un des seuls au monde y en a pas plus
de 5 qui peut déclencher le feu
nucléaire qu'à penser l'homme françois
mitterrand lorsqu'il est devenu
détenteur de cette clé nucléaire que
c'était la charge la plus lourde parmi
celles qu'il m'avait été confiée
si l'oisillon nous allons retourner à
-cp
philippe harrouard d'autres questions
oui c'était exactement la question que
je m'apprêtais à vous poser monsieur le
président parce qu'elle était souvent
posée ce soir mais maintenant c'est fait
alors voici également un thème qui est
souvent abordée par les téléspectateurs
par exemple un retraité de paris un
professeur de paris également
la retraitée de saintes ou de nos 77
ne pensez vous pas qu'il est temps de
rencontrer monsieur andropov ou un haut
dirigeant soviétique
j'ai rencontré il ya très peu de temps
monsieur gromyko qui est un trait aux
dirigeants soviétiques chacun de ses
ministres des affaires étrangères depuis
plusieurs décennies et nous avons parlé
2h30 rayonnons des choses à nous dire
quant à rencontrer monsieur andropov il
n'y a aucune raison de s'y refuser dès
lors que cette rencontre pourrait être
utile à la paix
je dois donc me poser à moi même cette
question est allé voir monsieur en
europe 1 avant la conclusion de cette
phase
j'espère être la première femme qui en
sera ce fils quelques autres de la
conférence de genève alors que la
décision d'implanter des euromissiles
les particulièrement des paires chine le
ne dépend pas de moi
qu'est ce que j'ai à négocier et qu'on
dort pas je serai amené à lui dire que
l' équilibre des forces exige qu'ils
réduisent considérablement son armement
s'il veut empêcher que les autres sarbe
cette visite n'aurait servi à rien et
rien de pire qu'une négociation qui
échoue par contre je reste disponible
pour tout échange utile dès lors qu'il
s'agira de reconstruire bientôt sur les
premiers décombres de la conférence de
genève
une autre question oui monsieur le
président c'est une question également
qu'ils aient souvent posée et qui est
tout à fait d'actualité pensez vous que
les événements de chypre tout récents
constitue un danger pour la paix nous
demande un téléspectateur un autre
téléspectateurs demande votre avis sur
la question de chypre et un autre
spectateur également de paris nous
demande votre avis sur cette question
tire la partition du nord officiel la
france a déjà désapprouvé cette décision
de ne des dirigeants turcs eux de faire
sécession en créant un sou disant état
du nord de chypre
nous avons déjà désapprouvé il existe
des décisions de l'organisation des
nations unies il existe une société
internationale nous n'irons pas la
compétition entre les turcs et des grecs
de chypre servent et nous voulons que de
droits des uns et des autres soient
respectés mais une décision de cet ordre
qui a peut-être été inspiré cette
décision n'est pas acceptable
donc ça c'est une première réponse
est-ce que cet événement de chivres peut
provoquer un conflit généralisé
certes eu la turquie et la grèce doit à
l'heure actuelle se poser des questions
j'ai déjà entendu l'écho des paroles
prononcées par monsieur papandréou le
premier ministre eux le grèce mais je ne
pense pas que les plus grandes
puissances veulent se saisir de ce sujet
pour alourdir un contentieux déjà si
difficile à régler pour sur les autres
questions
bon je pense qu'il ya d'autres questions
alors philippe oui absolument une
question je me posais en fait de
questions qui je pense sont sur le même
thème la question d'un monteur en ptt
qui vous demande ceci quels moyens de
pression avez-vous sur les deux super
grand et puis les questions d'un
marinier duhart qui vous dit
pourriez-vous être médiateur lors d'un
conflit amérique union soviétique moyens
de pression militaire dans leurs débats
présent aucun bien que il s'intéresse
plus que je ne le voudrais
à nous
politique et bien parce que nous disons
parce que nous affirmons parce que je
dis dans les assemblées internationales
je pense rencontrer une opinion générale
qui comprend fort bien que pour sauver
la paix il faut l'équilibré des forces
est qu'on ne peut pas laisser en europe
un pays tout puissant et des autres et
d'autres qui seraient désarmés
ça se comprend très bien donc ce que dit
la france par ma voix compte je le crois
dans l'évolution de l'opinion universel
quand être médiateur je ne me pose pas
en médiateur j'espère seulement avoir
l'occasion de donner d'utiles conseils
le jour venu pour favoriser un retour au
dialogue
et si je peux y contribuer cela me
suffira
philippe harrouard monsieur le président
je ne pense pas que l'on sorte de notre
propos ce soir par cette question qui
nous est souvent posée par exemple un
agence d'assurances d'orléans vous
demande le fait qu'il y ait des
ministres communistes au gouvernement
nous met il à l'abri d'un conflit avec
l'union soviétique
c'est une question que je n'attendais
pas je dois le dire je pense que le fait
d'avoir des ministres français est une
suffisamment intéressante pour l'union
soviétique qui ne doit pas se préoccuper
tellement des nuances politiques de
chacun d'entre eux j'ajoute qu'une m'a
pas semblé en 1981 lorsque j'ai pris des
ministres communistes se l'être fait
tellement plaisir à l'union soviétique
m'enfin des journées ce qu'ils
m'entendent commenteront ce propos à
leur guise non mais monsieur même si on
fait je m'adresse à ceux qui me pose la
question
monsieur je n'ai pas du tout l'intention
que mettre en cause le patriotisme de
qui que ce soit et le gouvernement de la
république connaît ses devoirs
il y a des français et je me refuse
considérer que je pourrai bifurquer
oblique et la politique d'indépendance
nationale au gré des personnes qui
participent au gouvernement de la
république alors toujours svp oui une
autre question monsieur le président qui
frôle peut être un peu la politique
intérieure la question d'un
fonctionnaire du pecq
on parle de plus en plus de conflits de
risques nucléaires ne pensez vous pas
que les graves questions qui se posent à
l'heure actuelle ne devrait pas être
résolu avec la vie voir l'accord de
l'opposition
mais je ne fus tout à fait des heureux
en effet de connaître le opinions de
différents partis de l'opposition plus
large sera le consentement mieux cela
vaudra dans les grandes affaires qui
touchent à la vie de la nation
je pense que la recherche de l'union
serait heureuse pour notre pays
surtout si cette recherche aboutisse et
étant bien entendu qu'il ne faut pas
tomber non plus dans la confusion et que
le débat démocratique
reste la règle et je n'entends pas
autour de mes propositions rassembler
tout le monde
ce serait déjà très bien et je pense que
c'est comme cela que l'immense majorité
des français considèrent leur pays comme
un grand pays qui mérite d'être défendue
capable de jouer son rôle dans le monde
de défendre la paix défendre sa sécurité
de défendre son indépendance d'être
présent par son rang par son rôle dans
le monde partout où il a des intérêts
historiques et puis aussi des trappes ce
pays a abordé les problèmes nouveaux
le problème qui se pose qui sont déjà
inscrits dans le présent et qui
conditionne l'avenir pense à la
construction de l'europe
je pense à la politique à l'égard du
tiers-monde
ou bien je pense à à l'édification d'un
un ordre monétaire nouveau voilà de quoi
faire
croyez le pour avoir confiance en son
pays le président leur tourne je pense
que nous allons prendre encore deux ou
trois questions dsv
il ya beaucoup de questions une question
qui a été souvent posée ce soir je
prends celle d'un chef d'equipe de
d'epinay sur seine qui vous demande mais
où en est la bombe à neutrons la bombe à
neutrons a fait l'objet d'études
ces études ont abouti nous sommes
aujourd'hui maître de cette connaissance
et donc de cette technique et le
suffirait qu'un ordre ceux donnés par
mes soins pour que la bombe à neutrons
soit construite il suffirait de notre
temps relativement court pour qu'elle
soit en exercice mise au service de
notre armée mais je n'ai pas donné cet
ordre
d'abord parce que je ne pense pas que ce
soit le moment d'alourdir le climat la
discussion alors que tout le monde parle
de désarmer tout en sueur rarement ce
pas le moment que l'avant ce qui a évité
à réduire les forces s'équilibrent par
la réduction vers le bas puissent donner
le signal futile psychologique d'un
armement nouveau mais je me réserve de
poster procéder à cette fabrication si
tel était l'intérêt du pays monsieur le
président oui un téléspectateur de paris
vous demande quelle serait l'attitude de
la france il ya un conflit en amérique
centrale
entre nicaragua états unis par honduras
interposés et on vous demande également
si vous êtes inquiet de la situation en
amérique centrale
je suis inquiet comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure d'un manque de justesse
d'appréciation des états unis d'amérique
dans cette partie du monde
je vois aussi où les guerre civile très
cruelle qui s'y déroulent peuvent peu à
peu porter les fractions à choisir
l'extrémisme plutôt que le juste
compromis donc une aggravation constante
de la situation mais en dehors de ce que
je dis là est d'une assistance dans la
mesure de nos moyens
il est évident que la france n'entend
pas intervenir dans un débat qui serait
pratiquement d'insupportable déjà cette
plus grande puissance du monde qui
consacre plusieurs jours à l'occupation
d'une toute petite île peuplée de 100000
habitants du vraiment c'est un spectacle
qui vous remet il pas renouveler ce
président je voudrais pour terminer si
vous en êtes d'accord vous poser une
question dont le philosophe glucksmann
dit dans son dernier livre
quelle est la plus philosophique qui se
posent à notre époque
cette question est la suivante il
faudrait revoir votre réponse là dessus
une civilisation demeure telle
civilisation
lorsqu'elle risque sciemment son
extinction pour survivre avons nous le
droit de prendre en otage femmes enfants
et des enfants des enfants sur l'entière
planète
cela me rappelle une autre citation que
je voudrais exprimer en termes exacts
elle vient de paul valéry
nous autres civilisations
nous savons maintenant que nous sommes
mortels et c'est vrai que tout peuple
tout ensemble de peuples qui composent
une civilisation pour reprendre les
termes de paul valéry
ce sont des corps vivants soumis au
risque de la mort mais ils contiennent
entre eux des germes de renouvellement
constant il n'y a pas de raison qu'un
peuple cesse d'exister et de se
développer à condition qu'il y mette le
prix
voyez-vous l'asie et ses essais les plus
merveilleuses pense en particulier à la
paix la paix ce n'est pas un don qui
tombe du ciel cela se gagne
comme le reste ce qui veut dire que pour
eux continué l'analyse de glucksmann de
l'essence d'une civilisation des valeurs
auxquelles on croit défense de son pays
cela vous bien la peine
l'apport de beaucoup d'amour le terme au
système que ceux là qui font parfois
sourire
enfin moi l'amour de la patrie le souci
de l'effort
si nous ne faisons pas personne ne le
fera à notre place
celui de la résolution car du courage
puis peut-être aussi permettez cette
intervention dans notre politique
intérieure que le sens que nous sommes
tous solidaires finalement devant
l'histoire et dans le temps cela
justifie que l'on réponde oui oui il
faut défendre ce que nous sommes en
tâchant de le faire mieux mais sans
jamais abandonner la tâche du président
je vous remercie
c'était l'heure de vérité notre invité
ce soir monsieur françois mitterrand
président de la république
bonsoir
[Musique]